when we tell a story we're entering into
a contract with the audience mmm Oh
video okay yeah can when you talk about
that what's this contract can we get out
of the contract um sure
you pay a price for it so basically when
you're saying when you sit down and say
I'm gonna tell you a story you are
promising something and and you know I'm
in the video I draw a comparison I use
the metaphor of your taking out a loan
from somebody and what you're promising
is that you're gonna pay back the loan
and that they will get interest for
their investment of attention and
attention is the currency that they're
that they're spending it's actually the
probably most important currency like
real world currency that we're dealing
with is the currency of attention
especially with the internet especially
the fact especially in the entertainment
industry literally entertainment is the
the industry of pain getting people to
pay attention so what you're doing is
you're promising that it's gonna be
worth it there's gonna be worth putting
their time into it so your job as the
artist is not only to present the
conflict in an interesting way but to
make it mean something to them and
that's that's where it gets very
subjective that's why you can have some
of the great storytelling and only a few
people will get it because it's it's
relative to like whatever psychological
dynamics or whatever value is resonate
with them can you give me an example of
a story that does pay off where the
contract is fulfilled and someone's
obligation is paid off and then maybe
one that it's not fulfilled mmm
that's a good simple one back to the
future will he get back to the future
right there and making a promise with
that title usually the the contract
you're making with the audience is right
in the titles right with the trailer
will you get back to the future you're
you're promising that in some way not
only are you gonna answer the question
but that you're going to enjoy the ride
and then it's gonna mean something when
he gets there and I do think that that's
you know ultimately you go
this whole journey it's Michael J Fox
who's endlessly entertaining and then
was Adam Equis who's just brilliant like
it's it's perfectly directed it's so
much fun and it's the movie that
everybody's seen so it's like I would
always use it as like the perfect
example of just like entertaining movie
like it's just a completely entertaining
movie so I do think it completely
fulfilled a contract you're entertained
the entire time and you're and then in
the end he gives you exactly what you
want in a way that you don't expect and
it's fun you know you enjoyed it but
along the way you're also learning
little themes like about you know this
high school teenager who's learning to
appreciate his family and learning what
his parents went through and like
that that actually kind of resonates on
kind of a more subconscious level where
it's like you know he he begins to
develop an appreciation for the
different generations and then how he
that story continues on his own life
he's almost reliving his dad's
experience yeah in some sense he's
becoming like because he sees that his
dad was you know not the most popular
guy in high school and was bullied and
then he's experiencing itself cuz he
stands up to Biff so yeah so then for
another example that I think is is
actually a really interesting example
look at No Country for Old Men now the
thing I love about the Coen brothers is
that they're constantly subverting their
own the audience's expectations they're
they're playing with it they they play
with the contract constantly which is
where that alienates a lot of people but
the people who are willing to take the
journey with them they find something
incredibly like much more rewarding so
with No Country for Old Men I don't know
if you read the novel as well okay
that's love Cormac McCarthy he's one of
my favorite writers
I was compared to like a if Hemingway
and Faulkner had a baby but he he so
Llewellyn Moss he's kind of the hero
he's the underdog in the story and
you're following this whole journey and
the whole contract is is it gonna mean
something that the well Llewellyn Moss
is gonna find this bag full of millions
of dollars go on a journey and change
his life and everything
gonna be awesome after that I'm we're
gonna get into spoilers here so okay
spoiler alert spoiler alert
so when he he goes to this entire
journey and in the novel they also did
this as well he gets to a point and the
sheriff Tommy Lee Jones character is
following him around and you think
you're waiting for this whole thing to
build up to this big explosive climactic
payoff where it's Anton Chigurh and
Llewellyn Moss and these they're both
well matched and they're there's this
hero and this villain and you're waiting
for the big standoff and it doesn't come
and instead Tommy Lee Jones drives up to
a hotel he sees just barely the
periphery of some standoff and well Moss
is dead and we never even saw it we just
see the dead body and immediately when I
first read it I had to go back and
reread it I'm like that I didn't miss
something cuz it felt like I felt at
first my first response was I just got
cheated they got me to invest in Lamaze
he's making this huge sacrifice why did
he do this but it was the fact that he
did subvert that contract that he did
subvert our expectations and then when
you see it in the movie they adapted it
perfectly where it's also it's
anticlimactic but it's the fact that
you're expecting the climax that created
the meaningful resonance afterward like
a the after that when you start looking
at like what did it mean that Llewellyn
Moss just died and it wasn't a standoff
in fact his wife ends up having to pay
the price as well she ends up getting
murdered by Anton Chigurh as well and
ultimately it's this question you know
it goes back to the theme that is this
No Country for Old Men like is this is
this some evil that's ancient that that
takes out that has like no mercy for for
goodness or kind people so ultimately it
really comes down to when you're paying
off a contract
you're trying to engage their attention
and if you do break it you have to have
a good reason for it so and you know art
is a bridge you know you're you're
trying to build across the waters to the
to somebody else's mind and so
ultimately you know every single artist
has different builds their bridges
differently you know Michael Bay will
build his bridge all the way across so
people can just kind of step on and have
a conveyor belt across and then Kubrick
will build this bridge halfway across
and the audience has to build their
bridge all the way halfway across and
they meet in the middle and then you'll
get someone like in vendors or someone
that you know it takes you on a journey
and you don't know where it's going and
you're pretty much building a bridge to
where he's at
you know but it you know and everybody
everybody decides every artist decides
how far they want to build a bridge
across the water don't you think though
every writer thinks that there that
there is a payoff that it makes sense to
them but unfortunately to an outside
view they may not see that payoff no I
can't speak for other writers um I sure
I do think that there is you know the
basic economy of story if you promise
something give it in a way that give the
you know the old thing the old adages
give the audience what they want the way
they don't expect but it really comes
down to the needs of the story what are
you trying to convey with your story you
know and I don't like imposing too much
of like to me what's really interesting
is when like finding the exception of
those rules until it actually until it
actually means something new you know
you